moment mal wir achten jetzt noch den
count oder rechts ob gekettet wurde ob
das wirklich so schnell wie peter tork
auto läuft 47 45 44 43
eiskalt der hat sich eiskalt so schnell
darüber gewinnt
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der hacker show wie
jeden sonntag wieder die es sind nicht
mal die lustigsten einfach die hacker
letzte woche ich sage dazu gar nichts
ich werte das gar nicht denn ich möchte
heute mal ein ernstes wörtchen über das
thema hacker mit euch reden
folgendermaßen es ist nicht cool zu
hacken es ist lustig für uns wenn wir
uns das anschauen wenn bereits gehackt
wurde dass also nicht mehr zu ändern ist
wir uns dann sagen ah ok wie blöd ist
der denn das zu machen wohlgemerkt
niemand sagt hier so wie cool ist der
denn direkt sondern wie blöd ist der
denn warum hektar wieso macht man sowas
das ist der gedanke dahinter also
nochmal hacken ist nicht cool wenn er
macht einfach nicht lassen das sind
einfach wenn er es unbedingt braucht
dann macht das auf einem privaten server
aber nicht vom öffentlichen server weil
es einfach nur das spielerlebnis der
anderen leute schmälert heißt ihr
verliebt in einen spaß wenn dann sagt
roma kooperation die community haben es
verdient dann wenn ihr irgendjemand
etwas was heimzahlen wollt wenn die
aggressionen habt dann geht in boxverein
oder sowas dann reagiert euch da ab aber
versorgt nicht anderen leuten die für
das spiel geld bezahlt haben die freude
am spiel und ist alle aller aller aller
wichtigste wenn überhaupt nicht mehr zu
retten seit und denkt ihr müsst
unbedingt hätten dann tut mir
eingefallen und kauft keinen hack client
bezahlt nicht auch noch geld für die
scheiße das ist das dümmste was es gibt
bezahlt doch kein geld für so was wenn
es braucht einen kostenlosen client aber
bezahlt doch kein geld für so was leute
euer eigenes taschengeld ist oder das
geld was eure eltern der wirtschaft wird
haben was sie erarbeitet haben gibt mir
für hacks aus was zur hölle macht nicht
so ein scheiß wirklich das ist wirklich
mein rat an euch wenn sonst gar nichts
mehr zu retten ist gib bitte kein geld
für so was aus ok so viel zu den ernsten
worten lasst uns jetzt zu den
einsendungen starten diese woche ist
einiges dabei
pack mas platz fünf
dann von blogs und heißt extremer hacker
okay man zählt also die einzelnen ex auf
will ich euch jetzt nicht sagen würde
nicht spoilern wir schauen was da
passiert ist
kibet wars ok steht hier scheinbar auf
irgendeinem motoren baut sich also ein
bisschen rum
okay immerhin fehler moschitz spieler
okay ich werde schon ok und jetzt oder
um stürmer aber nicht zwar nicht der
hier unten der widersinn die ja wohl
alles klar
das ergebnis die ecke geflogen habe ich
darum runter
so in 30 blocken hhh aufnahme ist sehr
gut miteinander das kalte wasser der
fälle klar das ist für range naja
wahrscheinlich alles auf alle endlich
seine hat deswegen auch die tiere
saubere was machst du heute vollkommen
außer kontrolle geraten jetzt wurde sein
bett abgebaute wen wundert's ist aber
gar speed 31 rüber gerannt oder hat sein
bett abgebaut sie an der sommer der
hacker als er getötet
okay wir schauen immer nach vorne zu
diesem moment wo oben auf einmal einfach
der typ stirbt man sie fragt warum und
damit auch mit getroffen und dann rast
vorbei und klatschte weg aber davon
nicht genug natürlich okay das war von
platz 5 wir springen zu platz vier
der stand von vanek style und heißt es
hacker schon okay sieht mir nach ender
games aus der jeans in die länder games
und klickst 20
was ist ist es klick und oben rechts mal
gucken was passiert
das ist aber kein känguru geht hier das
ist bisschen theorie känguru babys
gefühl
alter schwede wieder ab denn durch die
gegend normalerweise würde man denken
okay ender games känguru geht aber das
nein das könnte
der könnte noch gehen aber der hier bis
zu viel und vor allem nicht der fakt
oder doch oder es ist doch keiner kann
es vielleicht sein dass er das känguru
geht hat und das dann irgendwie ab deuce
irgendwie irgendwo eine lücke im känguru
kit weil er hat sonst nicht kennen
killat irgendwie folgt wenig hacks
vergleichweise bei macht so ganz
komische sprünge ist einfach zu viele
der zum beispiel was zur hölle können
auch server lag sein aber jetzt gucken
wir mal einen chat und untersteht kit
von atom putzer dem typen der gerade im
getötet wurde ist känguru also hatte auf
jeden fall des kangoo kit aber das
wissen die leute dort kennen ruck gibt
oder und das s springen kann
aber das ist zu hoch dass ich sage das
ist nein ich glaube dass es zu viel zu
viel jump fürs kino hit ich mir nicht
sicher
und ich finde das ist auch wichtig in
der hacker schon dass man nicht die
eindeutigen hacker hat und weiß
gekleidet direkt sondern auch ein
bisschen eine diskussion sich entwickelt
genau hier sollten wir diese diskussion
führen also frage geht es an euch war
dass ein hacker oder nicht ich weiß
durch das känguru kit mitsamt aber sohn
krassen doppelt so hoch so weit dass ein
bisschen komisch aus eure meinung dazu
gerne in die kommentare
für zu machen das hat mal kurz und
knackig und springt weiter zu platz drei
platz 3 stammt von angel ag gl und er
schreibt krasser hacker auf tv und wenn
man sich mal anschauen könnte man ja
schon mal vermuten dass der vielleicht
irgendwas nicht ganz fit ist wenn der
typ der einfach in der luft schwebt 20
bürger am boden
ok senkt sich darunter von einem
erhöhten punkt auf dem man gerade war so
aber er meint krasser hacker heißt es
wohl doch jetzt kommt ein zeitraffer
fast so hell und es ins grübeln was ist
dass man moment mal wir achten jetzt
noch den counter rechts ob da gekettet
wurde dass ich wirklich so schnell hat
okay konter läuft 47 45 40 43 eiskalt
der hat sich eiskalt so schnell darüber
gewinnt was zur hölle machen und dann
natürlich ein bisschen die killer am
lusen da drüben ich freue mich
tatsächlich weil ich etwas einwenden
kann und zwar ja was soll man das war es
ist eiskalt kein katyn dieser stelle
drin
der hat sich 50 blöcke hoch und 200
blöcke wald einfach innerhalb von drei
sekunden gekostet und ist nicht an
gestorben so sei es kalt ist schwarzer
punkt am himmel flut stelle der titel
krasser hacker trifft glaube ich ganz
gut würde ich sagen so viel vom platz
drei wir springen zu platz zwei
platz 2 stammt von konflikt oder
konflikt und heißt dieser bedways
spieler gewinnt die runde ohne einen
finger zu bewegen ok wie geht das nicht
ich spiele zwar kein banjo oder so wenn
man eigentlich interessiert mich gar
nicht ich wer ist der typ in dem wie
immer etwas gewinnt aber ich bin
gespannt was er da alles klar also er
hat wohl der menschen die kette dran der
aufnimmt crytek okay vielleicht
irgendwas den map raus
die zweigeteilte okay da geht's weiter
übliche verdächtige wieder schlägt bei
der gegner auf einmal klassik nimmt das
bett mit
die anderen gegner dran ist kein speed
hektik für speed hat nicht mehr gereicht
einfacher partner gleichen block
hinsetzen und los sein wird ich dachte
eiskalt aufgrund des teams ist dass der
typ irgendwie aus der map rausfliegen
deswegen gewählt ich hab mir das video
eiskalten nicht angeschaut bevor ich
hereingenommen haben ziemlich reguläre
gleitet eigentlich aus passt würde ich
sagen ja
tragisch dadurch schon eine ganze
familie aus mit seiner kühle aura aber
der date der bub ist es reicht eiskalten
nicht für uns bietet bei ihm und wenn
dann für minimalen minimal ist schneller
very sad story damals ihn erwischt hat
er gerade scalzo aus dem turm
rausgeschaut als er das bett aufgebaut
hat schneller ist also keineswegs hat
ein kleines aber nix dolles platz eins
platz eins stammt von jojo und heißt
hacker rage mode er hat die ganze
geschichte offensichtlich ist eine
kartoffel aufgenommen aber ich hab so
ein gefühl dass es sich lohnen dürfte da
reinzuschauen
wenn die cam ist der neue
kartoffelsorten wenn die eigenen worte
aber so schlecht sind dass man sich
selbst ins gesicht schlagen will ja
worauf warten wir eigentlich schon rein
kommen so alter das sind locker locker
240 ps ist yu chien schlecht ist sascha
häcker der hacker in dieser runde würde
ich mal so vermuten dass lolita also
zehn pfeile auf einmal schießt ach ja
und er ist auch um dach warum das
verwandte auf also schießt du zehn
pfeile auf einmal ja hier
maschinengewehr
ok also mal leicht maschine weg sieht
man auch an der wand wieso papa papa und
hier wieder 20 verweist aber auf dem
dach ware auch kann man sich ja auch so
nicht hin streckt mit freiheit so dass
beide und jetzt
der typ ist im alter übertreibt einfach
so krass jetzt passen wir auf hier wenn
er jetzt um die ecke geht der typ ist
einfach im boden wie kann man im boden
sein das ist der hacker wie kann man im
boden sein oder kann aus dem boden raus
schlagen es ist der neue maulwurf heck
oder wie park oder heck also das wäre
mir neu dass wenn next level face will
man einfach die ganze zeit im boden sein
könnte es format bereiteten wir nur
kopfschmerzen und mister maschine wird
stört ist ein nobler 0,2 auf einmal
neues marco fischer kam der 19
weiß noch niemand außer ihm machen
gerade auf platz zwei nach und steigen
einfach auf höhe von 50 blöcken so kurz
nach diesem aufstieg da am ende dennoch
das video irgendwie alles okay jetzt
reicht er sagt das war's für diese woche
danke für diese kartoffel einsendungen
mit
ich weiss nicht wie vielen hacker
vielleicht mehr mitgezählt ziemlich
fertig gemacht ich habe jetzt keine
worte mehr firma ab und deswegen doch
eins haben auch leisten